Manchester Airport is the third largest airport
in the UK
we have two runways, three terminals
handling over twenty-three million passengers
a year
So there could be a variety of issues that
we deal with.
So I got involved with the Airport Optimization
Project
through the Engineering and Physical Sciences
Research Council Sandpit
We talked about the issues that we have
and we set them to task of coming up with
identifying solutions.
Taxiing is important because it links together
the other problems at an airport
so you have the order in which aircraft take
off and land
you have where they go at the terminal building,
the gates and taxiing links these two things
together.
The ground movement is particularly important
because if you can get a better prediction
of taxi times
you can better predict when aircraft are going
to arrive at the runway.
Because of that you can actually hold them
on stands for a bit longer
If you can hold them on stands for a bit longer,
you can start their engines a bit later
Which actually gets you much better pollution
benefits as well as financial cost benefits,
because you burn less fuel.
We need to try and solve the problem using
optimization techniques.
Understandably airports are reluctant to share
their data with just anybody
I started looking for ways to try and get
data about taxiing at
a whole bunch of different airports with different
characteristics around the world.
One of the things cloud computing does is
it brings the power and the data processing
ability
of huge machines to any researchers desk.
I'm really positive about Azure, I think it's
a great platform.
What it gave me access to was a scalable,
powerful machine that I could use to do the
job that I wanted.
Part of this project, I have written three
open source tools available on GitHub
and they are SnapTracks, TaxiGen and GM2KML
and these all take care of different aspects
of processing data connected with airport
ground movement or taxiing.
I was pleantly surprised by how simple it
was to use open source tools with Azure
Linux, OpenJDK, SSH all worked just straight away very easily.
The computing power that we've got now has
allowed us to analyze data
in different ways and to pull out different
pieces of information.
So we can actually understand a lot better
the true uncertainty in taxiing
so we can understand which aircraft take a
long time to get there, which aircraft get
there very quickly
and we can understand under what circumstances
this is happening, which means we can optimize
the system as a whole.
As passengers we all have experienced various
delays at airports
and if those delays can be reduced by more
efficient operations obviously that benefits
us all.
Azure really made this research possible in
a reasonable time frame.
I had quite a big amount of data that I wanted
to be able to get through
and I was able to process it in something
like a tenth of the time I would have done
on my desktop
So rather than spending several months waiting
for my data to be ready, I had it within a
couple weeks.
Aviation is an industry that's growing, so
there are lots of ways that the industry
is trying to tackle the impact that growth
could bring to the climate.
So the Airport Optimization Project feeds
into that because we want to reduce the amount
of CO2 that's generated
when an aircraft lands, taxis and ultimately
departs from the airport.
The Airport Optimization Project is going
to be really important
to make sure that we maintain the efficiency,
safety and passenger experience.